wow
that was made with love yeah yeah you
did that yeah thank you you did that
thank you
hi i'm farren hey i'm lauren and
michelle and i'm richie and today we're
swapping cultural foods i would say i'm
jewish emphasis on the ish i'm here
representing the african-american
community i'm an american from
zionsville indiana i grew up on a
reservation i'm mexican and native
american how long have you been together
i'm gonna quiz you on this so we've been
together for seven seven years we've
been together for three plus years three
now three and a half years i cook he
does not cook i'm trying now you're
learning
she's allergic to literally everything
that is delicious in the world
we did have a battle with the amount of
seasonings that i used so
i use a lot of seasonings now
so i brought sweet grits you can put
sugar in your grits don't let anybody
tell you otherwise so these are burped
peanuts they're a peanut with a caramel
around it they're really good and
they're really sweet and they used to
eat them all the time as a kid okay here
we go
it's very good
it tastes peanuty
oh i totally forgot you don't like
peanut butter
was it supposed to be burnt no okay no
it's not that was on me it was that was
on me yeah it's gritty thank you what's
in the name would you eat this as a
regular snack uh probably not
so all i got here today is this
wonderful chips named doritos 3d when i
was a little kid and thought this was
the greatest thing of all time i present
to you kielbasa sausage traditionally
it's called pulse got kielbasa
all right
oh
please smell
all right okay
i'm ready i love meat let's do it
whoa that almost tastes like
bologna i'm not a huge fan of bologna
this is like
soft and oh not mushy per se but it
doesn't have like the like
so i
don't like it yeah as i keep eating them
i think i kind of like them i'm not too
sure it's just a little bland
european food is bland like yeah i'm
getting europe i'm getting europe in
this bowl yeah i eat these
we can have these in the house
i mean like traditionally you steam it
oh that's even worse and that is what i
did for you
so
next food
latkes latkes are potato pancakes
they're always served with applesauce
and sour cream i love them i mean
they're honestly just like a jewish hash
brown no one can dislike them so this is
the good old lunchable pizza all right
let's try this
did you toast them as a kid are you oh
you ate it like this oh no
do i put the sour cream first the sour
cream is disgusting
both yeah and a little bit of parsley if
you want
no i'm just kidding okay well we can do
that
all right
[Music]
yeah that's really good with sour cream
with the sour cream you can't remember
those things they are delicious but i'm
just wondering like are people out here
eating just like applesauce and sour
cream and then they're like you know
what i think would be good with this i
put it on a potato i don't know we
should we should open a history book
i have the star of every
thanksgiving do you need a chat
[Music]
sweet potato pie is like all that i care
about around thanksgiving and my whole
family knows it like i'm so excited for
you to try this so one particular snack
that we had was bread with condensed
milk and i used to eat this all the time
either at the breakfast or a snack oh
even more
so he's in for a treat
this looks a little slimy
trust me it's gonna be good
here we go
[Music]
so good
[Music]
something
better than pumpkin pie
actually
yeah
i mean
i like it that's good that you thought
you like it
[Music]
i like the dorito 3ds a lot and then
the pizza i liked like i'm glad i got to
check that off my list of childhood
treats i never had i don't think i'd
have it again i think i would have
enjoyed it more than as a kid
i am very glad that we have a majority
of the pie left over tonight i think we
know what we're doing for dinner yes
yeah and i'll eat luck is all day any
day i love your culture thank you for
bringing this into my life
it was a fun experience to see like the
things that you ate as a kid
because i think we had two very
different lifestyles that was really
cool i keep thinking about those doritos
man they're so good
anything else you want to say
mommy
i translate for you i'm the translator
of your book
why are all these people there i made
some changes
what have you done to my book
oh my lord i know it